When I'm with you, I don't want to be with you.
New whip, oh, out of the journey to 260.
Diabolical.
Diabetic.
White hair and a hopeful smile.
You're inside, it's on your outside.
Pleasant surprise.
Well, that didn't go as planned.
You think if the belt was the right tightness, you would have got it?
I don't know.
No way of knowing, but I thought it felt pretty good.
Boom.
I thought it was a grip issue.
The way that you kind of looked at your hand, the way you wiped off the chalk off the bar for the next attempt.
I was doing that the other time.
Wasn't there?
Can't be mad.
Wasn't there.
It's okay?
No, I got something I can work for.
Is that the new one?
Yeah.
Tell me it's better.
I mean, it's definitely better, no doubt.
Did he send you this one?
Non-butter.
4K 8-bit?
10-bit.
Is it?
One inch sensor, apparently, too.
The quality of my opinion is not good as like the Sony RX, but still solid.
Oh no!
Hey!
Fruits?
Green stuff?
Who are you?
You don't eat this kind of stuff.
You're just frontin' for the cameras.
You're just virtue signalling in the deli aisle.
Smoothie cam.
I'll come back, David Lee, to my home kitchen.
Denny's!
I'll see if I can pull him up.
Sing and cry.
Valhalla, I am coming.
Always sleeping.
So green, the whispered tears of gold.
Of how we call the times of war.
We are your over now.
Big day to day clock.
Big meet and greet today.
Is it a meet and greet though?
I know a fraction of it is.
Now that you say something like that in those words, I agree.
What's my oatmeal?
Wow.
What's up on time?
When will I find?
What is in this life along the way?
Don't you run and hide from truth you desire?
Everything lives one way.
Oh, oh, oh...
Oh, oh, oh, oh...
Once upon a time, where both I find, purpose in this life along the way.
Don't you run it high, from truth you desire?
Everything is on waste.
You need cool air, baby, I'm not fooling.
I'm gonna give you my love.
I'm gonna hold on to love.
You've been learning.
Baby, I've been learning.
All of this good time, baby.
Baby, I've been a dirt man.
I'm way, way down inside.
Honey, you made it.
I'm gonna give you my love.
Oh!
Hello, hello, hello.
To achieve your goals, do anything, anything.
Stop talking about it and just keep doing it.
That's something you'll do, you will fail.
And from those failures, you will learn.
We all can't just make mistakes.
Haters gonna hate.
But let them.
Titan crew!
Ugh, what's up Titans?
They asked me.
Do I train fasted?
No.
I actually have four eggs and four egg whites.
Before training, what would be the point?
I would tell you I was a jujitsu state champion.
We were raised by OGs, not IGs.
They were raised by pussies.
Slow it down.
When I'm lifting, every day is my life's workout.
Hey, let's put some music on.
You hear that?
Sawyer clot the psycho?
Don't worry about it.
It means you're doing something.
There's a thing called science.
And the science will show you what's possible and what's not possible.
There is something that's called heart.
They can break that.
You can't beat the guy that never gives up.
I'm that guy!
When I'm with you... Every workout is my last workout.
Yeah!
I was not always this strong guy, you see.
I went through a lot of hard times in my life to get here today.
All I wanted to be was an iconic man in my whole life.
I'm lunching at 225 on my back in the parking lot, and I remember just like, okay, no one else is doing this, so I'm going to do it.
And that's what my mindset was.
That was how I, like, mind-fucked everybody else.
I used to train in the middle of the night because no one else was doing it.
It's like, man, is that the secret?
Is that okay enough to do it?
Is that what we are?
The best you can for that day... You know, it comes down to what you want to do.
You want to be a champion for a day or a champion for, like, What are you talking about?
Men are so interesting.
We just get together on a late night, and to see who could put the heaviest thing on her back, it like lifted.
Shhh... Shhh... Shhh...
Ssssssss...
Super quick, before I close out this video, I just want to give you guys a few updates and just say a few things.
I know it's not common for me to make content, or at least I make it pretty infrequently, but these past two months have been extra difficult for that because...
Maybe about a month and a half ago, up to that point, for about a month straight, I had a very, very successful bulk.
I finally was able to hit my stride when it comes to a consistent caloric surplus.
And I was just gaining so much weight and training was feeling fantastic again.
I was holding so much water, so much carbs, none of my joints hurt.
I just felt very, very powerful.
And it was really, really fun to be able to bulk like that.
The reason that I think that happened is because, one, I just really made it an effort and priority to be able to bulk.
Because for me, as you guys know, I don't really have the best appetite.
And for me, a lot of times, it's just not my absolute greatest desire to be able to hit a caloric surplus every single day because there are trade-offs.
For instance, when I'm bulking successfully, legitimately my entire day is essentially...
shoving food down my mouth all the time feeling lethargic and miserable and is having about two to three hours of glory in the gym of feeling like a god but then outside of that I'm just just super lethargic so the benefit for me for really not bulking so much and more or less maintaining my weight is that I just feel more freedom throughout my day to do other things and just enjoy other elements of like life essentially and that was a trade-off that I was willing to make For a decent bit of time,
but then I hit a point where I was like, you know what?
I actually want to take bulking and gaining weight a lot more seriously and I was able to do that.
And like I said, for about a month, month and a half, that went very, very successfully and training felt amazing.
And I was planning on continuing that process until I maybe hit around like 220 pounds.
That was like my rough goal of how much I wanted to bulk to.
And then I got sick.
Literally me and everyone that I know got sick.
There must be like something going around but I just kept getting back to back to back sick and just you know fever congestion and sore throat all that kind of stuff but the most annoying side effect of all those was a murdered appetite.
I had no appetite whatsoever and that was just extremely unpleasant and so training just hasn't felt the same and then when I'm not training as much...
I'm just less incentivized to just want to film things, make content, because it's just... it's just how it is.
But anyway, finally getting out of that.
I'm starting to feel better, but geez, this has been one of the longest that I felt this way.
So anyway, enough rambling about that.
Hope you guys enjoyed the Attila's vlog.
I had a lot of fun at this Attila's event, like a lot, a lot of fun.
Jim Shark.
Right?
And Attila's like we finally made like a formal event with one another.
And that's going to be something that we're going to be doing a lot more in the future, just going around different iconic gyms, you know, around the US, around the world and just making events there.
And it was just really cool that we were able to do Attila's for the first one because that's my personal, my favorite home gym that I've been training at.
And speaking of events, there's going to be another event in about a week from when I'm...
I'm filming this, or a week from when I'm going to release this video, and it's going to be in Miami.
A lot of you guys might know about it if you follow me on Instagram, or if you follow Jimshark on Instagram.
But I just want to let you guys know here, in case you're not aware, I think it's going to be February 24th to 25th.
Huge event in Miami.
You know, I'm going to be there.
So many athletes are going to be there.
You know, meet and greet.
Basically, if you've ever been to Jimshark event...
It's likely going to be like that, but better.
And if you haven't been to the Gym Shark event, you may be seeing some of it on my YouTube channel or other people's YouTube channels.
I highly recommend going.
It's a very, very fun time.
And we've never done anything in Miami or Florida.
So it's going to be interesting to see how that goes.
And I'll leave some information on the screen if you guys want to know the address and all that.
You do need tickets to go.
And the tickets are free.
And I'm pretty sure there's some left.
So make sure to get those tickets.
And yeah, I'm just excited for my training to finally resume.
I'm starting to feel better again because I'm just... I'm not going to keep going on about how poor I felt, but feeling better.
Training is going to be better.
I'm excited to make a video for Miami.
I'm excited for that event.
Hope you guys enjoyed this Attila's video.
Just want to say thank you to everyone that came to that.
So yeah, I'll see you guys in Miami.